- It's five in the morning. Woo!
(light piano music)
Today we are going to the River Ganges
to perform the last rites ceremony
for my grandfather, and deposit
his ashes into the river.
It's such a difference
from New Delhi yesterday,
because that was like totally yang
and this it totally yin.
One thing that I struggle with a lot
is like worrying, over-planning.
Today I saw something so special
in the unique fusion of
messiness and beauty.
All the crazy wild animals,
and then this happened.
There's a cow, right there.
Seeing all the crowds of people.
And this bridge.
This looks like a storybook!
Can you guys feel the bridge moving?
- I was here when I was three years old.
And I remember vaguely that
I had a really hard time
getting on the bridge
because I was so scared.
And my father just grabbed
me and I was screaming,
and he took me across (laughs).
- I was expecting the last rites ceremony
to be very sad, but I was surprised
with how much peace
and closure it gave me.
The tragic event of my
grandfather's sudden death
incited my first trip to India,
and in coming here I have seen a glimpse
into the hard work and sacrifices
my grandfather made to create
the best life for our family.
I feel a responsibility
now to work even harder
for my dreams, and to fulfill the path
that my grandfather paved for me.
We just finished the
ceremony for my grandfather.
Really glad I came to do it.
I feel some closure,
but I'm still processing.
I love how colorful this country is,
both literally and metaphorically.
How in this culture, something as sad,
terrifying, and mournful
as someone's death
is remembered in a beautiful
celebration of their life.
You never really know
how special something
or someone is until they're gone.
Sometimes you have to travel halfway
around the world to discover that.
I challenge you today to tell a friend
or a family member how much
you love and appreciate them.
Because you might not even be aware
of the sacrifices they have made
for you until they're gone.